what's up guys bang-bang
I've got been here what's going on man
I'm doing pretty well obviously I've
been quarantined myself two Fridays ago
I've been in my mom's house and I got I
got 11 acres so I go outside and I
didn't use my chainsaw cut my disc golf
course in quite a bit and I'm actually
been listening to a quite a few of your
podcast that keeps me busy trying to
read books trying to get smarter it is
hard with three young kids at home but
doing my best
awesome what uh why'd you quarantine
yourself two Fridays ago do you feel
sick no not at all I just felt it coming
you know all the schools here in
Wisconsin said this is our last day that
was like Friday wait today for a Friday
March 13th all the schools Wisconsin
said well you know we're done for a
while the colleges did so my brother and
I decided hey we should probably close
our I can't even follow suit with the
schools there's no reason to try to
stick out you know especially when you
know I'm not an epidemiologist I don't
know how this is gonna turn out so I
don't want to stick my neck out there
and say everything's fine we're good
like I don't have to know so yeah I said
hey listen I'm not I run my businesses I
might as well just stay at home and be
extra safe and then you know but by
early the next week man everyone else
was kind of doing the same I was good
actually getting really annoyed that
weekend that was March 14 15 because
everyone was going out and partying and
stuff and even though there's their
offices were closed and school is closed
it's like you idiots like this is the
last thing you need to do just sit over
e to F a book or something I love the
kids I went to spring break and I a man
let's the spring break comes once a year
we're going sure they really work I mean
for what it's worth at Spring Break it's
all college-age kids so you know that
that group is very little risk for the
co kids so I guess as long as they don't
see their grandparents they're all good
yeah what's it like running the
businesses right so you guys have the
wrestling academies and stuff what's it
like been there you got to shut down and
how are you handling that well lucky
that Friday we looked at a bank account
it looked really nice so he said you
know hey we can afford a couple months
of shutdown and and still pay our rent
and pay our employees but we've already
had so unfortunately last month we
bought a new we bought an existing
Wrestling Academy to add to make it our
fifth Wrestling Academy and we also
bought a building for another came that
we were starting so those are kind of
not ideal times purchases seeing as we
shut down like two weeks later but Bank
of the West they already reached out and
they said they're gonna do a 90 month
deferment on our mortgages so that you
know obviously makes it easier so where
does we're lucky we're in a really good
spot where you know we're not
cash-strapped we're I mean you know
those unemployment numbers are crazy and
you got to imagine that you know if this
lasts we would I think we're kind of
like two weeks ish into the nationwide
quarantine maybe a little less than that
do it I feel like if this lasts another
month from now
man there's gonna be a lot of people
going bankrupt and so I you know I don't
feel like our government's done a lot
for the small businesses a 1200 chicking
and keep people out of bankruptcy so
there I think there has to be some type
of nationwide deferment on rent payments
and then I also feel like all my wife's
when I feel like so 16 days now is two
to two Sundays past this one I think if
their business aren't reopening or in
some way shape or form and maybe there
are safety measures that people are
started getting really really really
antsy oh yeah
I mean look part of this whole thing is
if you're a small business you know
you've got maybe an hour two three maybe
four weeks of cash those unemployment
numbers were people who saw the writing
on the wall immediately and fired
employees but how many businesses have
held on to employees and said hey you
know it's gonna be a week two weeks
three weeks but as they start to run out
of cash they're gonna get rid of
employees as well right and so you're
going to see those unemployment numbers
stay pretty high I think if if this
thing doesn't turn around
but it's the balance between the health
crisis and the economic crisis I don't
know if there's a right solution yeah
it's between is between a rock and a
hard place and I've been following this
pretty close since it was in China and I
don't think their numbers are accurate I
think that's probably highly highly
unlikely at this point although I don't
know for sure and it just feels like
it's not nearly as deadly as was
initially thought because they weren't
testing everyone and stuff like that it
also feels it feels like there's a
possible medication kind of on the
horizon here you know there's that
clerking [ __ ] looks like it's kind of
having some positive results in some
places that testing so hopefully we are
getting a handle on this you know when
you put the brainpower of the world
behind it
problems can tend to be solved for sure
what um what's the general census do you
think in in kind of the non-coastal
elite areas right so you're in where
Wisconsin what are most people thinking
are they quarantine themselves
yeah they taking it seriously or are
they just like this is full [ __ ] oh
that's how they were initially and now
you know I said everyone that weekend
where they said all the schools are
closed in everything else everyone went
party I'm like golly what are you people
doing and now I think there's been a
shutdown non-essential business is and
so I think people are taking it
seriously people are worried but I could
go check but I believe the stats uh is
that that world have you check out that
world Demeter's website I saw it once I
haven't looked at it recently though
yeah it's fantastic it's a breakdown by
it by state by state which you know New
York and New Jersey are significantly
over half of the total coronavirus cases
so Wisconsin still at seven hundred
total cases in the whole state and ten
deaths so you know when you're seeing
those numbers obviously there might be
an uptick in the future but that's still
like a really really tiny amount yeah my
my father is in his early 60s and I
called him and I base because I hey man
you know without freaking out can you
just you know make sure you're washing
your hands stay inside you know eight
six and vitamin C boost your immune
system like all the kind of know
stuff and he literally said to me
because I take a multivitamin I'll be
fine
oh man that's yeah that well that's it
that generation I feel like you know
people were trying to [ __ ] on the
Millennials I feel like that boomer
generations like ah did whatever I'm
gonna go out and eat I'm gonna go out
and do whatever I want
F this thing yes I think it's pretty
interesting in and also the other piece
of it is the gun sales like that that's
the thing that surprised me the most
when you layer in the health and the
economic crisis gun sales have exploded
across the country and I don't know how
much of that is like people actually are
fearful versus just that's their natural
response but that's usually not a good
sign when it comes to kind of social
unrest and things like that right yeah
well I I think I think it's a fear
response
you put that article on the liquidity
crisis which I thought was really good
but I think it's definitely a fear
response I don't own a gun I didn't go
but it didn't go buy a gun
someone price you took and John Jones
gun away
and so I don't see it getting that bad I
mean you never know I guess we'll find
out obviously the conspiracy theorists
out there saying you know they're gonna
roll at the National Guard and do
martial law I take all of our civil
liberties away I don't foresee that
happening but yeah I guess you never
know yeah what let's talk about John
Jones
he just got a DUI with a gun charge all
this stuff but my understanding is that
he was actually sitting in the car
asleep right he wasn't actually driving
I don't think he was driving at the time
but I like he was sitting idly you're
sleeping cuz they said they said the
reason that the officers respondent was
because there was a gun shot which is
apparently his gun because there was
like I apparently an empty casing or
something found so I don't feel just
shot in the air but the part that was
the most crazy to me is he says
something like he was intending to drive
again later like why would you tell them
that like this makeups just some kind of
lie he said I was driving and I'm
intending on driving more later and it's
like Oh
for God's sakes just tell them like you
know you came in here just to listen to
the radio or I don't know make up some
type of lie but you know your your
vehicle is not actually moving so you
could probably if you weren't idiot you
could probably argue that one away in
court somehow I'm guessing I don't know
yeah
the I think it was you they just said
hey why don't you just hire your buddy
right and just be your driver for you
for like 50k a year and just stay out of
trouble I said that the last two times I
mean this is it this is his third DUI
this is not this is not time number one
is this time time number three it's like
and you know he obviously has other
people with the best interested in
whether it's his coach his manager
people who sponsor him Dana White the
UFC president I'm you know if jivey
didn't roll John Jones out three times a
year that's can be a lot better than if
you can't for a year and a half which
dude I mean three duis I think that I'm
pretty sure that's mandatory jail time
in most states plus the add-on the fact
that he had a loaded weapon and it was
fired and he had weed and if the man do
the drugs he probably born there I'm
guessing so yeah I mean how they haven't
found it I actually just did a live
stream on this the other day I had this
dear you won't hear my theory pump if I
want to hear it okay I have this theory
and I I'm in the process of putting it
all together actually knew who kind of
inspired me I started I talked to a
couple times I've listened to him on
your show and I somehow connected with
him on Twitter with sampar oh yeah yeah
he's grant him on the hustle maybe maybe
yeah maybe two or three weeks ago you
had him on and and then I listened to
that and then somehow we connected
through Twitter and yeah we got a call
he kind of like I've had this idea about
showing him a head for a while and he
kind of pushed push me a little further
into it but but the idea is that success
is a skill and you have all these mental
characteristics that are necessary to be
to be successful in something that being
said different things take different
sets right and the more of these
societal like 500 categories the more
they set you could put together the
better off you mean so for example being
an athlete
especially being a cage fighter
something where there's a high-level
risk you need to be really low anxiety
for exhibit was one trait of the many
traits right but if you're all worried
oh my god this guy could kick me or you
could punch me if you choke me oh my god
there's 20,000 people watching me oh my
god I could get knocked out right
there's all these things you've always
if you're high anxiety you're probably
not gonna have a high level of success
so John Jones is really arrogant low
anxiety those type of things are great
attributes to have in mixed martial arts
and you know that I can't get in trouble
no one can hurt me type mentality great
it's great that's great you want it
there and so then I you know the
argument I'm making is like well number
one you should you should work on your
weakness but number two especially if
you John Jones and you know you have
these weaknesses and I use the simple
one for myself listen bro if there's ice
cream and cake and cookies you're on I'm
gonna eat it so when I'm dieting for a
fight my wife is not allowed to buy it
we don't we do not have it in the house
ho because I will eat it I know I'm weak
like that so it's like John Jones you
know you like to drink and you know you
like to drive put some roadblocks in
your way before because when it's 3:00
a.m. in the club and you're drunk and
the cars out there you had the key
you're gonna go drive your you know
yourself you know you're going to do
that you know hire yourself a driver
have a couple friends around they're
really responsible and put roadblocks in
your way so you can't make these dumbass
decisions over and over and over again
which are in fact ruining your life yeah
it's pretty crazy because I think
everyone knows kind of what their
weaknesses are some people want to admit
it some people don't but if you are
willing to admit it to yourself that you
could put those roadblocks in place and
kind of prevent the issues from
resurfacing over and over again yeah
yeah I mean that's that's a huge one so
yeah my I need to put this in a prior I
have a couple different like psychology
theories that I don't believe have been
written about too much and this is one
of them and so you know not like another
example would be well you're gonna be a
husband soon right you got your engaged
in you yes I did married right okay so
like as a husband and then eventually if
you're gonna be a father
you know for example empathy is like a
gigantic quality to be
the help but as an athlete dude the more
empathetic you are though it's gonna be
it's gonna negatively affect your career
so there's these certain qualities that
are like okay if you're gonna be a good
husband a father this set of qualities
is really really really really important
if you're gonna be an athlete this is
really important if you mean a business
man this is important if you're gonna be
entrepreneur right because entrepreneurs
are different than employees so
employees are gonna need a different
skill set that an entrepreneur is and so
the idea is that you know you got to mix
and match your mental qualities and then
you know eventually I think most people
would probably like to be diverse enough
to have success in multiple areas like
you know I got to assume even the guys
making billions of dollars but have just
terrible personal lives I can't say this
for sure but man part of that part of
them part of them has to be like
miserable because they can't keep a good
relationship they they're distant from
their kids right or whatever because
they have they probably these really
great qualities that that allowed them
to make a billion dollars and those also
probably sabotage them in their personal
life so understanding when to use what
quality where yeah I think it's super
super important I actually just thought
resurfaced a while ago somebody asked on
Korra what separated you know the Elon
Musk's the Jeff Bezos etc from other
business leaders and Elon Musk's ex-wife
went on and answered and she basically
was like it's obsession but you
literally have to be obsessed with being
great at what you're doing and solving
the problem and thinking about it 24/7
that also makes you horrible and other
aspects of your life yeah yeah and
that's where it's like for me I mean the
I guess that would probably my number
one issue and I try to do a good job of
it but but being aware that it is your
personality type and then that can't be
a problem and I always joked with my
wife not always joking because sometimes
she gets annoyed with me but like when I
was a high school kid or college kid I
was obsessed with being good at
wrestling and the fact that I didn't
want to really go out and party and I
was just worried about being good like
everyone saw this that's freaking
awesome like and you know you get a pat
on the back for it then if you're 35 and
you know you just want to be obsessive
about your
work and your wife wants to go socialize
it whoever or you know people see you as
being like weird like why can't that guy
go socially a little mother effer I just
want to be good at what I want to do but
at some point that becomes unacceptable
it's weird it's all it's all priorities
right I always tell people that some of
my favorite advice is like you hear
these you know somewhat dumb simple
statements like you know the five people
you hang out with the mostess who you
become show me your circle and I'll show
you kind of how successful you will be
all these things but it's true right it
really is true yeah and I think that uh
the other thing is you're getting judged
by people who don't understand that
right the people who think it's a
negative thing
they don't understand kind of the
benefits of it the people who do
understand it they're like well duh of
course you're going to want to focus on
what you're doing and be obsessive about
it etc yeah well so yeah I mean but I so
I do I see I definitely see my wife's
point and I think there's a balance to
it so it's like you know expect
especially with especially my kids you
know I can't I can't imagine not giving
them attention so they're like you know
I said two side points of time to give
my kids lots of attention and then you
know other people maybe maybe not nearly
as much as I should or whatever but I
try to do my best
what's going on with the Olympic
wrestling I know that you obviously have
a storied career there and it looks like
the Olympics recently got postponed what
are you hearing yeah postponed by a year
I was really annoyed when they first
said it because it was like ah it was
what a week I think it was last Sunday
last Sunday they said hey give us a
month to see how this shakes out and I
thought hey that sounds reasonable and
then on Monday Canada and Australia said
we're out and and then they said they
cancelled it by that night so it's like
within 24 hours all that happened and
it's it's almost so wild how everything
is going to happen actually I recorded
my funky crypto podcast on Tuesday and
you know we did we actually put it in
put out till Thursday and we actually
had usually been waiting Tuesday in
there putting out the following Monday
that's six days and I'm like I don't
really like that because so much can
happen over the course of six days and
sir Tuesday afternoon we record Tuesday
night they dropped six trillion dollars
and it's like well that would have been
relevant to talk about the thing to me
that's so interesting about what's
happening right now is exactly what
you're talking about on the Olympics
people are saying the prudent thing to
do and the non-emotional thing is let's
wait a month and they'll make a decision
but then all of a sudden there starts to
get this pressure and it's like social
pressure and everyone gets really
emotional and next you know bandits
cancel you know wait a minute 24 hours
ago you guys were singing a different
tune but that's not just happening with
the Olympics it's happening in finance
in the economy with businesses with the
health response etc and I think people
just gotta kind of calm down and breathe
a little bit before they make dumb
decisions yeah I agree I mean just just
be patient and it's like it's crazy
because stuff changing so fast it's like
every single week you're gonna know so
much more about what's happening I mean
if you think about where we're at last
last Sunday or Friday I mean and where
we're at today and then think about
we're gonna be next Friday I believe
it's uh they're they're way different
places and I think it's that it's a
little bit of that kind of woke culture
where everyone's trying to be more woke
than the next person I feel like that's
kind of the way that this is played out
yeah the and here's the sad point right
it's like you almost have I take the
coronavirus stuff take like all the
epidemiologists and the data analysis
you get people who say hey we think
500,000 people are gonna die in Europe
and 2.2 million in America and like
basically the world's ending and then
all sudden they come back and they
retract it all and they're like well we
actually think it's like 10% or less of
what we originally thought so you get
like that where people then get pissed
off and they're like dude what the hell
happened to your analysis but then you
see a picture of a nurse with like a
trash bag on or you know inside the
hospital you're like yeah this is real
right it's super dangerous but also what
the hell's going on with this data
analysis yeah I agree too and I think I
think the thing to remember about that
is man you know what I have all these uh
I know these theories I just forget the
names them do you remember the name of
the theory that if you
you say you're an expert well you're an
expert in Bitcoin right say on the front
page of the newspaper you read an
article in Bitcoin you're like okay
that's [ __ ] but then you flip the
page by the next page you forgot that
these people writing the articles aren't
actually really experts and you trust
where they're saying on page 2 you want
the Timothy Rios I don't but it's
definitely a valid theory because that's
exactly what happens in the mainstream
media okay well so that is valid like
that happens and so it's like with with
something like this it's something
that's never ever happened before and so
it's like okay you would say I'm an
expert at mixed martial arts and then
too you would say well I trust you to
tell me how Tony Ferguson versus khabib
is gonna play out and you know what I'm
gonna probably give you a better guess
than most people because I'm a pretty of
an expert but you know what it's also
never happened before and if I'm totally
wrong that could happen that's a
possibility so I think of it I think the
same I want these experts it's like
they're going in there shooting in the
dark they've never been through this
before they can guess but they don't
really know and so that's again when
people take fire for sure action on
stuff that is not proven not known
you know people making their best guess
that it can be dangerous
for sure I am I keep going back to all
of these people have opinions and they
have their kind of expert analysis but
whether they're right or wrong there's
very little skin in the game right that
there's very little kind of negative
impact if they're wrong but you and I
are sitting at home quarantined and so
we're being negatively impacted whether
they're right or wrong and so the the
incentives were just really off yeah you
know the one I like to think about on
that one the people at TV of those skin
in the game is that watch this really
really interesting interview I came from
or who it who it was but they said you
know insurance companies are some of the
richest companies in the world do you
really think do you really think they
would insure all of these beachfront
condos and apartments and properties if
they thought they're gonna be underwater
in 20 years no they wouldn't
so the people who actually have skin in
the game aren't really worried about the
sea level rising five feet or ever it's
it's all the other people if the
insurance companies really thought that
was a possibility they wouldn't insure
these place someone oh yeah because they
have billions and billions and billions
of billions of dollars invested in this
it's so true what ah what do you been
doing well on quarantine just playing
with your kids and reading and stuff er
you've been doing other stuff uh
podcasting so I do the flow radio one I
do one per rudest I do the funky crypto
podcast and I do funky and FRB with
Brian which are mmm a podcast so if
you're doing those done a few of the
interviews reading I said building my
disc golf course and playing with my
kids and yeah that that's about it and
forth like even with our businesses
there's like not any work to do because
it's literally nothing's going on we
don't know when things are gonna start
back up so it's not leave you plan for
status I like okay April 13th we're
going again we don't we don't know so
it's not only we can plan for things in
the future so yeah that's that's about
the extent of it it feels kind of like
Groundhog Day a little bit where you
just keep waking up and do some of the
same stuff over and over again you know
you got to do so I got two guys who've
been helping me with all the audio stuff
Ryan and Joe Ryan's birthday was like
five days ago and so every day I get on
the phone I tell him happy birthday he's
basically Groundhog Day right so you got
to tell him happy birthday at some point
that is funny yeah it does feel like
Groundhog's Day a lot I mean it is like
the same thing over and over and over
here at least I have my podcasts keep
you on schedule because you know the
flow ones every Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday so I got to get up and get
going for that one please at least get
my day started hey let's talk about
Bitcoin cuz you're smarter than I am
and I was out you know eatos did this
group chat yesterday type thing I can't
remember exactly what they called it but
it was really cool because I got to get
on there and there's a few people on
there who I like I always search Bitcoin
Twitter you know and just I don't they
don't follow them but I pay attention to
them
and I got to you know kind of chat with
some of the people who I follow Twitter
so that was really cool and I got to go
out a good opinion so obviously I'd like
to hear your opinion because everyone
has one of why the price is not rapidly
rising at this point yeah I mean look
it's a liquidity crisis right meaning
that everyone wants dollars and so every
asset is gonna get sold off whether it's
stocks commodities Bitcoin whatever it
is and people want dollars but as soon
as that liquidity crisis ends either
because there's a flood of dollars that
enter the market through intervention
from the government or people realize
wait a minute I don't need as many
dollars as I previously thought I can
now go buy other assets you'll see those
prices stabilize and ultimately recover
and so the the beauty of all of this is
if you understand how money works you
don't get shaken out when the liquidity
crisis happens right if you can kind of
weather the storm and hold your assets
but also you've got cash kind of cash is
king right and he who has the cash makes
the rules and the liquidity crisis yeah
yeah I bought a couple more Bitcoin at
five thousand when it dropped down there
I thought I thought that was a good idea
I thought that was really really nice
price and I never thought I could get
some at that price that being said you
know what as I search Bitcoin Twitter I
feel maybe more nervousness then I've
ever felt from that crowd and obviously
when you see when you search that you're
gonna get all kinds of responses all all
aboard you know you're gonna have 27
people saying the price is going to
$3,000 you have twice that people say
prices go to nine thousand tomorrow you
know it's like people are all over the
board but there is uh you know not
everybody but there's a certain amount
of people who are nervous because and I
believe you said this also but it's like
this is the perfect storm for Bitcoin so
either it's gonna make her it's gonna
air or it's not you know either it's
gonna prove that it is this safe haven
asset and it's it's better than then the
USD or it's not and we're gonna probably
find that out within the next three to
six months yeah so I I kind of believe
some of that but some of it I disagree
with and so the way I look at it is it's
definitely the perfect storm right
you've got a quantitative easing you
have to
and having all this stuff with that said
I don't think it will happen in three to
six months I think it's more of like 18
to 24 month time frame and I don't
necessarily think that if Bitcoin
materially increase in u.s. dollar value
in that time frame that bitcoins done
right like I don't think that it will go
away I don't think that it'll be you
know I'm not secure excetera
what I think is people will have to go
back and revisit what the thesis for the
asset is right because that wouldn't
serve kind of this idea that the having
an inflation hedge asset etc proved to
be true I'm still in the camp where I
believe that pretty strongly voting with
my dollars that way and kind of
converting them to Bitcoin etc but you
know what we'll see what happens over
the next two years give or take yeah
yeah the other thing that I find
internet people aren't really that they
don't ever bring up on Bitcoin Twitter a
lot of people bring up that the u.s. is
gonna print six trillion dollars but no
one brings up the fact that bitcoin is a
it's a worldwide asset and the number
that all of the central banks across the
world is gonna print is way way way way
more than six trillion dollars I mean I
don't want to say every central bank and
start printing money but a lot of them
are and so the numbers gonna be I don't
know double that triple that so there's
gonna be all this extra money floating
around that that could find its way into
Bitcoin yeah there's this guy Brent
Johnson that I recently brought on the
podcast I run something called Santiago
capital and he's got this theory that he
calls the dollar milkshake theory and
it's this whole idea of everyone around
the world the central banks were making
a milkshake what they're doing is
they're injecting liquidity into the
market to printing money right they're
injecting it into the market but only
one country gets to have the straw to
drink the milkshake and he says that's
the United States with the US dollar
because everyone wants dollars so
everyone's injecting liquidity in and
the US is sucking that liquidity out by
bringing it all in to the dollar and so
the reason why he believes that is he
thinks the dollar will get much stronger
etc but if you kind of take that example
a little bit
further you get this idea of you know
look at the Australian dollar the
Australian dollars fall in like 30 40 50
percent in the last couple of weeks
against the US dollar so all of a sudden
if you're in Australia it's not so much
that you want to just get out of the
Australian dollar you either want to get
US dollars or get Bitcoin well a lot of
times bitcoins going to be more
accessible than getting US Dollars and
so I think that you're right in that
like on a global basis there will be
more demand for the asset as you see
those currencies being devalued yeah
yeah that's it's serious I I've been
saying a bunch lately that I wish I had
a thousand be the college wrestling
coach in Missouri and then I started
doing MMA and you know my path my path
to my life is probably not the way I
love it but it's not the way I envision
it now I always wish I would have taken
some economics classes and I'm you know
I'm doing my best to read up and you
know listen to a good podcast but it's
like there's so many opinions on what
the six trillion dollars is gonna do
some people are like oh my god they're
idiots
the feds gonna end some people are
saying oh they have to do it you know
and it's interesting because which one
of these opinions is the right opinion
and there's probably not one true or
correct answer based on what your
perspective is but I wish I had a better
grasp on that one yeah and I also think
that you know there's a big difference
between what else should the Fed do what
kind of they have no choice but to do
this to solve the short-term problem
versus is this a good long-term decision
so I think a lot of people yell and
scream about you know hey I like what
they're doing I don't like what they're
doing and it's a very binary
conversation but instead if you look at
it as the money printing solves the
short-term problems but it also that
same thing that's good today may not be
good in the long run both of those
things can be true right now and that's
my personal view is kind of where where
we're headed
short-term they have to do this but
long-term it's gonna be detrimental yeah
well how do they just like how do they
rein it back in is it because you know
this is like when you go back to the
success thing if you want to be
successful at something and
and you get off-track and you're kind of
not doing that well there is always a
period of pain to bring yourself back to
you know whether it's like you're a
wrestler and you got to make a boy class
and you get extra heavy well there's
gonna be a period of pain what are you
getting back into it right or you you're
an athlete and you get out of shape and
then to get back in shape using extra
painful and if you would have just
stayed in shape so the a period of pain
is gonna come in some way shape or form
what that looks like I'm not really sure
but I know that has to happen yeah so
there's a really good example here which
is a crack addict right and what ends up
happening with the crack addict is at
one point they're sober then they try
crack for the first time they get high
they like it they try it again they get
high again next time they go to get high
they gotta take a little bit more crack
right and over time it spirals into them
taking more and more of the drug to get
the same high and eventually they're a
crack addict right they take too much of
it they can actually overdose well the
economy is no different right there was
a period of time where there was no
stimulus then we introduced stimulus
once it worked we liked it then there's
another chance to do it we did it again
we liked it and you keep kind of doing
it over and over again but the numbers
get bigger and bigger in order to get
the same impact so during the 2008
crisis we Hawking in hundreds of
billions now we're talking in trillions
right if it happens again we'll be
talking in tens of trillions you know
then hundreds of trillions etc and so I
think that once you get started you
can't get off of it
the only thing you can really do is try
to control it or be somewhat prudent
about when do you use stimulus and how
much of it do you use but what's an
economy is addicted to stimulus there's
no going back but doesn't that but then
how do you so obviously like you've seen
let's say Germany did the hyperinflation
and what the 1920s and they got back on
track somehow right and and I'm not I
don't know the history of the German
Republic obviously know there was a
World War two in there so I don't know
if that was part of it
not sure I don't want to comment but
they obviously got back on track to
where say in the 1990s their dollar
there their form of currency was pretty
strong so there was the hyperinflation
at some point in their history and I
know that's also an other
entries so the isn't there there has to
be you know you say there's no way to
get back but there has to be a way to
get back to sound money principles in
some way shape or form well so what
usually ends up happening is there's a
currency failure and a reset of the
economy and if you really think about it
without going into too much detail
there's a lot of things around
defaulting around debt you're having
like a reset of everything you can even
create a new currency I guess what
Venezuela's trying to do right where
they're actually trying to credit this
digital currency that's a new form of
currency so there's things that people
can try to do but it's just in the form
that you started you that will
eventually fail in the end look it's not
just economies right like take like the
ubi thing so in the car a stimulus
package they're talking about a one-time
$1,200 check you know or less to adults
if they had instead said we're gonna
give $1,000 a month to people for 12
months let's say right I don't think
that we could go back to not doing but
people would just get addicted to
receiving $1,000 a month from the
government right and so then all of a
sudden I seen you know ubi and they kind
of like backdoored it in through through
this emergency time period so I think
people just kind of it's always great to
say we're gonna do something temporarily
but normally we don't go back and this
is how we got off the gold standard
right is in 1971 yeah we're gonna get
off the gold standard and we just never
went back well is that isn't that
personal income taxes also was initially
the what was the victory tax with World
War one or World War two there was no
personal income tax and then hey that
was nice let's keep doing that and then
they just kept it well now what people
are saying is why do we pay taxes if
they can just print as much money as
they need right why do they need your
money
sir-sir seriously right let's keep on
putting this [ __ ] absolutely so what uh
in terms of like the folks that you talk
to on a daily basis I feel like a lot of
folks are in a you know sports wrestling
eminates MMA etc like what are they
talking about when it comes to the
economy are they worried you know do
they understand what's going on or is it
kind of just hey I'm focused on myself
individually and just
to get through this um well I'm not
talking to very many people because I'm
stuck about freaking house but that
being said I thought this you know Peter
Peter Schiff brought up I camera how he
said it but he said essentially there's
no more interest in in Bitcoin there's
no one new to come in which obviously I
think it's wrong it's the to two points
that number one I thought it would be
very interesting is well are you seeing
more people sign up or more people
Google you or something like that right
and so I actually asked that question
with each world yesterday some of the
you know some of the top people in there
were and they said yeah we were
absolutely seeing it we're not as they
saying a surgeon buying from new people
but we're doing searches and signups
there's a lot of people doing that type
of thing and then I don't remember who
the guy was but he said on that day
where Bitcoin Kratt were the whole
economy crashed and bitcoin crashed
he said the amount of Bitcoin mentions
was 4x the highest day in history on
Bitcoin mentions on Twitter and then
what I'm seeing personally is that I've
had more people ask me about Bitcoin in
the last two weeks then ever ever ever
ever since I started talking about it in
2017 yeah I think people are starting to
realize because here's the playbook and
this is the part that gets really scary
for folks is when they do this
quantitative easing the people who get
hurt the most or the bottom 50% of
Americans who live paycheck to paycheck
and don't have any real assets right
because they're their dollars get
devalued yeah and so I think it's going
to be an education opportunity for a lot
of people as to how they can protect
their wealth from inflation and
quantitative easing so it shouldn't
surprise us to see people already asking
and I bet you that those enquiries go up
more over time yeah I would guess that's
I think if there's a especially if
there's some type of break out in price
over the next eight to weeks because I
know um let me just check
I think the Dow is down again today but
obviously had been up and I don't know
why these idiots get so excited about oh
my god it's the largest street again in
history
yeah dum-dums because it went down the
larvae the largest two-week loss in the
history right I mean obvious that's why
it's up a little bit but I think there's
gonna be a huge amount more volatility
especially when you consider what the
volatility of the Dow is usually like
and I don't think we're done going down
and so at that point when it when it
stabilizes that's why I think people are
going to feel more comfortable moving
their money elsewhere yeah did you see
the chart there's this guy
toppy Costa who he shared a chart from
the Great Depression and in the chart in
October of 1929 the SMP 500 plunged 34%
in a month and then over days it had
this relief rally of 18% and then it
plunged another 26% over the next two
weeks and so it's kind of very similar
theory how similar it is to what's
happening right now where you go down a
bunch over a month get two or three days
up and then all of a sudden it's likely
you're gonna go back down pretty
substantially and it just shakes people
out right you just get people shaking
out of their positions who were buying
in over the last two or three days
thinking that this thing was over yeah
yeah I mean it's yeah obviously there's
been a whole bunch of ups and downs over
the last week and I get I'm not
economist so I can't can't say for sure
but you know with the unemployment
numbers going out when my wife and I
went and walked our dog yesterday with
our kids and it was like there's no
stores open this is this is effing
creepy it's like they're probably not
gonna open for a while
the numbers on the money they're making
the numbers on a employment dude it's
it's gonna get worse it absolutely is
and so the fact that you're seeing that
you're seeing literally the entire
economy shut down as I Drive around but
yet the stocks are going up like how the
f does this work out like this this
doesn't you know it doesn't feel right
in any way shape or form
yeah it's like the the fundamentals are
getting worse but there's price recovery
which means that there's even more
dislocation and when you get the
dislocation between price and
fundamentals it means there's farther to
fall right because basically that you
know 13% person or whatever has been up
last couple days it's just gonna get
taken back away what it
your kids think right now like what the
quarantine do you understand what's
going on uh you know they do we've told
about who people are sick and that's all
we can't can't go around other people
and so they get that part of it about
how did they understand the scale or the
scope and you know they're kids they
don't really get it so that they're
they're enjoying themselves for the most
part yeah they probably just enjoy not
having to go to school my daughter by
first grader she's only she loves school
actually she's like really sad she can't
go she loves it it's funny she is uh one
of the few I guess right yeah yeah
absolutely that's for sure got it
so what um what are you excited about
once we get out of the quarantine stuff
anything that you guys have on the
horizon it sounds like you've got some
more of the academies coming online but
anything else going on yeah I mean we
were so we and Heartland here our first
Academy we're on ninth year max in
Mequon is in his seventh year and it's
like we're still seeing this crazy
amount of growth so we got after the
high school season was over we got that
one week of our kids before the
quarantine thing hit and it was like do
we see so many new faces people are
getting excited about it so our
businesses and you know wrestling's what
I love we're going to new levels and
we're really excited about that and so
the fact that we had to shut it down was
like was really really depressing so I'm
excited for that
obviously I'm excited for some type or
form of stability to happen I'm excited
to see when all of these things are
gonna get rescheduled because we you
know we had so many things that have we
cancelled and so it's like there's it's
just weird this crazy time right now
where we don't know when this is gonna
end we don't have any answers we don't
know when anything's gonna get
rescheduled or anything like that so
it's just uh I think I like other people
are excited for some stability to come
back into our lives
yeah where's the interest of wrestling
coming you said a lot of young kids who
watch like UFC and they want to get into
it or they actually see the wrestling
and want to do wrestling not so much UFC
in the future
um yeah I don't see that UFC thing a lot
you know I think we are just doing a
great job marketing or giving kids great
experiences and that's why our Academy
specifically they're growing but if you
look at like even than say the numbers
of Big Ten viewers
BTN it was up like 40% from the highest
ever and so I think that's full flow you
know directly attributing a full
wrestling and other businesses who are
you know putting media around wrestling
when I was a kid or even even when I was
at college a decade ago you couldn't
really watch live wrestling anywhere and
now with all the live streaming
solutions you're able to watch pretty
much anything that you want to watch and
so it enables people to actually be fans
you know when you about you or I were
kids that they gear a couple years
younger than me it's like we couldn't
watch something that was not football
basketball or baseball like we were fans
that cuz cuz really literally because we
had to be cuz it was the only thing on
TV and now you could watch whatever the
hell you want to watch streaming pretty
much anytime you want to watch and
that's that really enables people to be
fans that that's what's happening in
wrestling yeah I remember the first
couple of times
ESPN showed like non major for sports
and people would be like wait what was
that right where did that come from and
it was whether but uh but they started
incorporate some of the other stuff and
then even like the Little League World
Series right when they started to kind
of same sport but just get outside of
the national and college levels no I
think people paid attention and now you
know what's crazy is I saw that I think
this past year LeBron James and Dwyane
Wade sons they play at Sierra Canyon
High School they had more national
televised games that Golden State
Warriors no that can't be right can it
or was it a smaller Network or something
wow it's well on ESPN well but think
about it right everyone all moan come on
right they they have a down here yeah
but you gotta remember social media
right I mean those kids probably have
more followers on social media some of
the NBA players sure yes
yeah you're right damn that's why I
could get up and I'm a the young kids in
wrestling right and going into college
etc they start to kind of build those
social audiences and that drives the
yeah the attention for the sport you
know as well yeah yeah you're right I
mean yeah you're totally right on that
it's one of arguments I made a while
back with with the UFC is that the UFC
the brand they they have a baseline
because people like fighting but it's
pretty damn low and stars are what drive
events people love engaging with people
and if you don't have those stars you're
not gonna drive numbers and that's just
and I think that's been shown whether it
was Tiger Woods in in golf right he
drove huge numbers or other people you
know basketball you know you see all
time so star stars Drive viewers and
yeah I mean that's a good point about
those guys and yes yes that is 100%
happening wrestling I can say that
without a shadow of a doubt who do you
think the big upcoming stars in UFC and
wrestling are that you're excited about
maybe somebody that like others don't
even realize are gonna be big stars oh
my goodness that is a that's a tough
question
well there's a couple wrestlers that are
gonna make their transition to mixed
martial arts is coming here bo nickel
and anthony Kassar they're they don't
want to have publicly stated that that
is their goal i think they're both gonna
be really really good at what they do
and you know i think we'll see even more
in the future where people in wrestling
are gonna go early and earlier towards
giving their intentions to do mixed
martial arts as they as they get out of
college not of wrestling yeah how hard
is it as a as an athlete to go from you
know pure wrestling kind of Olympic
style and collegiate etc to the actual
mixed martial arts where they're
striking and kind of a stand-up game etc
is it really that hard no it's easy it's
frickin easy
most people who like wrestling are very
combative they don't mind you know
getting hit or getting struck and
sometimes when you shoot and wrestling
and you hit either a knee or a hip when
you're taking a pen tray
man that's that's that's worse than
anything that is like catch a hip write
to that like I write there it was
terrible and so you know I think people
yeah people go from wrestling to mixed
martial arts you you very very rarely
see a guy who's a high level Russell who
does not have success in mixed martial
arts it's almost unheard of not it all
right well I appreciate you jumping on
now what um where can people find you
online so that they can they can track
you down and and get in touch with you
if they want yeah I'm just a pen Askren
on Facebook Twitter and Instagram
although I really like Twitter
I don't like Instagram so much I use it
a little bit I don't use it a lot bit
and yeah I got a bunch of podcast and so
you'll see me posting those on my social
media so you can find me there
and I appreciate you having me on I'm
excited to see you know what happens
with with Bitcoin in the next month two
months three months of things to be
fascinating to watch obviously have to
having him 40 roughly forty seven days
yeah so there's gonna be fascinating to
watch and see see the future of fold
right in front of our eyes long been
long Bitcoin and long the academy's my
friend will do it again soon I
appreciate it but you gotta think you
appreciate it